[Music]
this is a business that addresses a real
operational problem in the dairy
industry this will be revolutionary for
food security in areas that don't have
reliable electricity
[Music]
India is the largest producer and
consumer of milk in the world today
dairy processors cannot collect from
more than half of the 300,000 milk
producing villages in India we have a
dairy farmer whose milking the cows the
bacteria starts to grow immediately and
if they don't get that milk chilled
within 4 hours that bacteria kills the
milk India is averaging six hours
dangerous levels of bacteria everyone in
India who buys milk knows that they have
to boil it which means you're getting
rid of all of the vitamins and nutrients
that come with that milk so you're
probably asking why the hell don't we
chill this milk at the village level
well a traditional milk chiller requires
a dedicated diesel generator to maintain
these diesel generators and to buy the
fuel for the diesel generators makes it
economically unviable for the dairy
processors to place these smaller
chillers at the village level we have
developed a thermal storage battery
system that enables dairy farmers in
India to chill milk for the first time
without a diesel generator the idea of
our technology is to decouple when you
get electricity and when you use that
electricity for chilling things like
milk of 300,000 milk producing villages
in India only a hundred and twenty
thousand are able to sell to the
organized dairy industry when we enable
a dairy processor to collect milk from
them they make three times as much money
per liter of milk and dairy processors
tell us that they've never seen quality
this good over the next five years the
middle class is going to be growing by
67% and they're all demanding more
quality products particularly when it
comes to food but there's a problem of
getting food to the market because of
the unreliable power to chill things
like milk fruits and vegetables and
that's the market that we're addressing
the impact will be that these dairy
farmers will make a lot more money
in a much more sustainable way and the
consumers will be drinking much
healthier milk so the whole ecosystem
Rises
you
[Music]